voici tout ce qui change au 1er
septembre la réforme des retraites
commence à être appliquée et l'âge de
départ à la retraite et progressivement
repoussé à partir du 1er septembre il
passe à 62 ans et 3 mois pour la
génération 1961 l'âge de départ
augmentera ensuite de 3 mois par an
jusqu'à atteindre 64 ans en 2030 pour
les générations nés après 1968 à Paris
les trottinettes en libre-service ne
sont plus autorisés le port de la Bagaya
une robe longue traditionnelle et
désormais interdit dans les
établissements scolaires le montant des
bourses étudiants augmente de 37 € par
mois les entreprises offrant des
abonnements en ligne doivent désormais
proposer un bouton ceux des abonnés
facilement accessible et réalisable en
trois clics sous peine d'amende cela
concerne par exemple les plateformes de
streaming les assurances les abonnements
téléphoniques ou encore les salles de
sport les prix maximum de la carte
avantage SNCF augmentent de 10 euros et
passe par exemple de 39 à 49 € pour les
voyages de moins d'une heure et demie
les voyages plus longs sont aussi
concernés la rémunération des
professeurs augmente d'environ 100 euros
nets par mois ce montant peut varier en
fonction de l'ancienneté ou d'émission
en région parisienne la RATP va mettre
en place un système d'arrêt à la demande
à partir de 22h les passagers vont
demander au chauffeurs de bus de
s'arrêter entre deux arrêts les ruptures
conventionnelles coûtent désormais plus
cher aux employeurs qui doivent
maintenant payer un forfait social de
30% contre 20% auparavant cela pourrait
avoir un impact sur le recours à ce
dispositif utilisé pour éviter les
licenciements ou les dém